now this is 8 news now live at 11
live local now thank you for joining us
on this wednesday night at 11 p.m on
brian loftis
passion determination and world-class
talent those are the qualities of an
olympic champion
including one of our very own las vegas
native bo
becker was part of a gold medal winning
swim relay team in tokyo
orco mana speaking to his family tonight
and orco joins us live with his unlikely
journey
to the top
well brian for swimming star boat becker
the road from las vegas
to the olympics in tokyo has not been
easy but his brothers tell me his big
win this week
means so much more than a medal
when i saw him when the gold medal
teared up
a little bit so it was a really
beautiful moment bobecker's brothers are
beyond proud of him the 24 year old
first time olympian and faith lutheran
graduate
celebrating a first place finish after a
stellar swim in the 4x100 freestyle
relay but his trip to tokyo was far from
a walk in the park
his journey has been it's been a long
and brutal one
beau has rheumatoid arthritis which
means his immune system attacks his own
joints
diagnosed when he was around 12 years
old he actually started swimming as a
way to help his condition
his older brother brandon telling me
even making the olympics was a miracle
he's almost given up several points and
just kept going it's been a testament to
his
tenacity and strength as a person bose
went with the sandpipers club in las
vegas and broke swimming records in high
school
and college but last year he almost gave
up the sport
he's just stopped swimming all together
the youngest becker brother cameron says
beau waited tables at a restaurant in
reno for six months but his passion for
swimming returned
leading him to the world's biggest stage
it's amazing to be able to look up to
someone of his caliber
and that i'm also related to him it's
surreal bose brothers hope he serves as
an inspiration to kids
everywhere battling illness or adversity
and never
giving up will get you good results in
life
and maybe a gold medal
now beau was only scheduled to compete
in the 4 by 100 freestyle relay at the
olympics but his brothers tell me that
team usa
might also add him to a different relay
reporting live from downtown las vegas
tonight
orca mana 8 news now